we've got some breaking news to bring
you this morning the chief executive of
the Scottish national party is under
pressure to resign today a member of the
party's executive committee has said
that there will be a vote of no
confidence if Peter Morrell who is also
Nicholas durden's husband doesn't agree
to go well our Scotland correspondent
Connor Gillis is in Glasgow where
morning uh Connor who got a leadership
contest we're in the midst of of that
what is going on with the SNP management
there are so many twists and turns when
it comes to this leadership contest when
it comes to the ruling governing party
here in Scotland the SMP Nicholas
sturgeon has of course held a very tight
grip on the SMP over the course of her
Premiership over the course of the last
eight years and when she announced her
resignation just a matter of weeks ago
it appears that the party machine has
been in free fall there have been a
whole host of issues around the
leadership contest and how the party is
being managed in this as you see this
points a lot towards Peter Morrow who is
the party's Chief exec Nicholas
sturgeon's husband and in the last few
minutes a senior member of the ruling
governing body the NEC off the SMP has
told me that there is a strength of
feeling within the NEC a strength of
feeling a very strong feeling that they
are looking for a resignation commitment
from Peter Morrow the chief executive
today or he will face a vote of no
confidence they are saying he needs to
lay out his exit strategy and he needs
to be clear with the party to allow them
to go forward and rebuild the Integrity
that many feel have been lost over the
course of the last couple of weeks now
let me just talk you through some of the
issues that the SMP has faced for many
weeks the calls around the leadership
process and the Integrity of that
has been called into question all three
of the candidates vying to the police
Nicholas sturgeon had no idea how many
members of the SNP were actually voting
in this contest a number of them said
that that was completely Preposterous
and that would happen not even in a
Bowling Club committee for a very local
committee never mind the Scottish
national party in the ruling governing
body here in Scotland those figures
initially were refused it was thought
that the SNP had around 100 000 members
at the last count and on every occasion
the national executive committee of the
SNP and the chief executive Peter
Morrell refused to issue those figures
even to the candidates in question after
days of sustained pressure and scrutiny
on the party they eventually decided to
reveal those figures and they revealed
that they had lost around 30 000 members
over the course of the last 18 months or
so and had lost roughly ten thousand uh
since the gender reform brow and the
gender reform debate around at Christmas
at what then led to a situation was that
just a couple of weeks ago the snp's
head of communications had been sent out
from party HQ to deny a newspaper report
that the 30 000 figure was incorrect it
said it was incorrect and it was utter
drivel now what has transpired is that
the party sent the head of
communications out to make that position
when actually it was true all along and
last night his position became untenable
and he resigned that is just the latest
in a long-running saga when it comes to
this leadership contest and is why the
chief executive Peter model is under
increased scrutiny and increased
pressure to resign and that may happen
today